hi I'm Khan Sean these are my kids Ilhan
and Noor and today we're gonna be using
up our Thanksgiving leftovers with
Google's new smart display Google Home
Hub hey Google us tasty to clean out my
fridge all right let's start by seeing
what you already have at home turkey
potatoes carrots thanks sure turkey
potatoes carrots and peas here's what I
found
oh that looks good you guys want to help
me shred some turkey our family
Thanksgiving I would say is a really
nice mix of traditional with a little
bit something special we always do a
more traditional style turkey with
butter and herbs we do carrots and peas
mashed potatoes but then we will deviate
from tradition and do things like almond
butter cayenne and maple Brussels
sprouts so I would say it's a really
nice mix I cook with my kids but I
always have to be mentally prepared that
it's gonna be a little exciting and
potentially chaotic but I'm okay with
that cooking with kids is a great way to
get picky kids to try new things hey
Google please add garam masala to my
shopping list garam masala is an Indian
spice blend with cinnamon cloves
cardamom black peppercorns it may seem
like garam masala is hard to source but
it's actually not that hard to find hey
Google where can I find gara masala
nearby I found a few locations for garam
masala near you
like a book ready to get this pie in the
oven hey Google please set the timer for
45 minutes
sure 45 minutes starting now all right
guys ready to set the table
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]